what's the carbon footprint of these
events every single year that you come
here you may remember Abby YY I've had
him on the show a couple times he's from
Rebel news he's an Australian journalist
he's an actual journalist without air
quotes uh he is at Davos right now at
the world economic forum and the morning
he confronted John kery about flying on
his private planes uh when he's always
worried about climate hypocrisy and you
might we watched this video and we
thought it was from last year because
he's done this more than once to John
krey but this is this morning what's the
carbon footprint of these events every
single year that you come
here you think it's worth it peasants
pay for your
crimes that's a stupid question is it a
is it really is it is it is it more
stupid than you traveling here to tell
us please sorry we're done we are done
no don't grab me you can't grab us this
is a free Society mate this is we are
free freedom of the press why do you
think you're more important your carbon
footprint doesn't matter but everybody
else around the world justed that nobody
ever suggested that don't make up stupid
questions you being here suggest that a
stupid question you being here every
single year and doing this suggest that
and and I have done a huge amount listen
to finished please why can't I ask him
questions who are you why are you trying
to bully me out of a no so please that
doesn't a lot of people say no to a lot
of the policies and agendas he
pushes they don't get a choice so why
can't we ask him a question in a public
space can you not touch me do you see
how much these people hate you John krey
has flown more he has a private plane
remember we've shown you the video where
under oath he said he didn't have a
private plane and then the congressman
was like uh but you do and he's like oh
no it's my wife's these people hate you
John krey has put more CO2 in the air
flying private than than than virt than
I'm sure for anyone that you know if
you're watching this show right now and
anyone more than I know they don't care
they will always be eating the fanciest
wagu Stakes they will always be flying
in their private planes and all he can
say is that's a stupid
question